there have been rallies and debates
there have been TV ads and lots of them
and there has been the traditional
shaking of hands and kissing of babies
but no the politicians are almost done
the people will soon have their say the
first presidential contests of 2020 the
caucuses in Iowa Donald Trump will win
on the Republican side that's a
certainty the big story will be the
Democrats there have been 28 Democratic
presidential candidates that are 11
still left in the race many of them
would have thought they'd spend the
summer campaigning across the country
instead their campaigns will end here in
the snows of America's Midwest the
conversation has largely been dominated
by discussions of Joe Biden senator
Bernie Sanders senator Warren and mayor
Pete Budaj
and I think those are the four
candidates that everyone is going to be
watching but this state is known for
producing surprises famously a
little-known senator called Barack Obama
won in 2008 and went on to the White
House other long shots have topped the
polls people who won the nomination have
finished second or third you don't have
to win here to be a winner the
performance of who finishes second and
who finishes third and fourth that can
have an effect on a campaign as well
moving forward you know certainly
whoever comes out of Iowa in first place
if there really is a true victor is
going to have wind at their back it's
going to help them in New Hampshire in
Nevada it might help them in South
Carolina but ultimately this is a long
primary season last-minute campaigning
has been difficult for the four senators
in the Democratic race they've been tied
to Washington for the impeachment trial
another missing big-name billionaire
Michael Bloomberg he was too late into
the race to register to run here he's
pouring money into his campaign hoping
to notch successes later in the process
from a group of 28 the field will be
much tighter in just a few days Iowa
doesn't pick the president but it will
eliminate several possibilities Allen
Fisher al Jazeera
Des Moines Iowa